on
[Musique]
le choc au deuil vous retrouverez dans
tous les manuels d'histoire de l'art et
de l'architecturé
il a fait école malheureusement il a été
donc à partir de là de la fin du xviiie
et bien le château a été complètement
détruit et les pierres ont servi pour
offert les agrandissements des cheveux
de valence est alors j'ai eu il ya
quelques années une vingtaine d'années
l'idée folle d'acheter des ruines du
château de voeuil inhabitée est en ruine
depuis 200 ans depuis l'époque
talleyrand et napoléonienne surtout des
courtines inférieurs sont du 15e
oui c'était un château de la guerre de
cent ans détruit pendant la guerre de
cent ans et donc on a reconstruit à
partir de 15 cents à 15 cents exactement
c'est jacques hureaux le seigneur de
cheverny car ça a été le premier chan o
cha li était la fenêtre et guerre on va
le qu'est ce qu'on appelle le
cristallisé c'est dire arrêtez le
massacre et surtout a donc essayé de lui
redonner un peu son faste d'antan
on a commencé les joutes on a commencé
donc à refaire les médaillons les
jambages les linteaux de fenêtres
à partir de 423 et bien les arbres qui
ont été faites avec voir à côté très
court italienne complètement réussi au
moins d argent on retrouve ça vous qu en
italie donc à la fin du cours rodtchenko
on va aller visiter maintenant la
chambre du roy et savoir pourquoi ça
s'appelle la chambre du roy le fils aîné
de droit de philippe venez ici et aurait
couché ici asseoir et les mauvaises
langues racontent ils auraient couché
ici avec la duchesse de didot la nièce
de tolérant mais bien sûr ce n'est
qu'une légende mais sachez que dans
toute légende
il ya un fond de vérité alors voici donc
la salle de réception on arrive ici
c'était le chantier lgv et des arbres
qui poussent et enfin c'était c'était
bien donc on a trouvé comme un compagnon
du tour de france frédéric chauvaud
encore plus fou que les autres qui a été
carrément dit veut pour tacle voiture je
me car faire et il y a été carrément à
la barbare il a tout refait la toiture
et ce qui est beau c'est que l'escalier
couple volume donc ça évite de faire la
grande salle uniforme et donc là on peut
recevoir pratiquement le club des 10 ou
sympathiquement 204
[Musique]
entrée nazis mode d'emploi bien sûr des
banques et ce avec sa comparse aider
toutes les pierres de deux du château
sans avoir à monter un échafaudage qui
coûta tous des faits et qui demandent
eux un mois pour être monté à mas poids
des mots
allez on y va on marque des cent
[Musique]
ça me rappelle toute mon enfance quand
j'avais 7 ans 8 ans à l'époque de mon
grand père
déjà ils fabriquent et bien évidemment
déjà cette huile de noix temps encore
chercher avec avec ses saveurs ses
odeurs exceptionnel
cette malle et remonte à 1850 1870 elle
était déjà installé où étaient présents
non grand père dans le coeur du village
on utilise pratiquement chaque jour
parce que l'huile de noix à l'ancienne
bah c'est le c'est le coeur de notre
huile riz c'est notre notre histoire
notre savoir-faire notre tradition c'est
notre emblème
nous sommes en photo avec mon père
philippe
donc cette photo a juste un an
d'ailleurs donc
donc voilà devant le le véhicule de
famille puisque mon grand père andré le
fondateur a eu au moins trois tubes h y
citroën moi je me souviens quand j'étais
petit j'avais entre 7 ans 8 ans 9 ans il
m'emmenait faire des tournées très
régulièrement à partir du travail de la
meule de pierre
la deuxième étape sera ensuite la
cuisson dans les poils est dans les
chaudrons en font
comme à l'origine c'est un savoir faire
il faut tout le temps être là à l'oeil
au à l'odeur aussi puiss on donnera
beaucoup plus de goût beaucoup plus de
deux couleurs beaucoup plus de saveur
vous avez un autre exemple l'huile de
noisette qui est très apprécié comme
l'huile de noix quand on embrasse comme
ça c'est pourquoi que sa grille au fond
c'est si sa grille au fond ça va donner
un mauvais goût à l'huile a un goût de
grillé et ça va pas être pauvres
[Musique]
un stock assez important huiles
végétales bien sûr biologique un de
première pression à froid il ya aussi
une partie des cubes qui sont destinés
aux huiles bio gourmande
elles sont déjà filtré mais
effectivement vont se reposer et très
souvent les re filtre juste avant la
mise en bouteille le conditionnement il
ya une cinquantaine de villes
différentes
et puis nous avons été récompensés l'a
dernièrement pour 2021
concernant l'huile oméga-3 forte
meilleurs produits bio donc pour cette
huile c'est une belle récompense pour
nous je vais vous faire découvrir
justement notre presse continue sur
votre droite là où on extrait
aujourd'hui de l'huile de cameline donc
c'est une
une graine qu'on extrait en première
pression à froid et donc cette huile est
très riche en oméga 3 vous avez un
circuit qui arrive est la graine va
entrer directement dans cette cage à
l'intérieur donc la grève est extraite à
basse température
alors des marigots en 1970 il fallait y
croire il fallait vraiment le faire le
résultat tout ça aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils forment une belle entreprise
familiale artisanale
[Musique]
à existe depuis 1902 c'est fini et à la
base elle reliait la ville du blanc
jusqu'à la ville de argent sur sauldre
c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle commune
accompagné du blanc argent il n'en reste
qu'un tout petit bourg sur la ligne en a
énormément de passage à niveau qui ne
sont pas dotés de barrières donc c'est
pour avertir les usagers de la route de
l'arrivée du tram dans tous les esprits
pourquoi ds puisque à l'époque la vapeur
c'était si fiers et on a gardé ce est ce
qui correspond au plateau
on est tous les jours
on les travaille et n'a rien à voir avec
le personnel habituel
f ça me confond s'arrête et tout
nous
c'est un petit mot sport
pour donner mon art est facultatif sur
la ligne nous avons plusieurs arrêts
facultatif donc c'est l'agent de
contrôle qui où lé voyageur et qui
demandent de quoi qu'ils vérifient les
cartes les abonnements et qui fait
arrêter le conducteur dans les arts est
facultatif on s'est beaucoup de
scolaires de gens qui ont l'habitude de
voyager sur ce projet là et du tourisme
aussi un peu et qui me rappelle aussi
avant il y avait le poêle à bois dans
les anciens ya un côté un peu
touristiques comme les trains tout ici
vous pouvez dire et ça m'est arrivé de
le prendre avec mes petits-enfants pour
aller d'un salbris exprès pour profiter
de la ligne
c'est très intéressant d'abord en plus
il passe dans mon village à une minutes
de chez moi
tiens plus
rangez vous avez deux réseaux le réseau
sncf awa normale et le réseau métriques
avec la compagnie d'hugues l'argent les
horaires de la compagnie de l'argent
sont calqués sur les grandes lignes sncf
sauf le matin où on privilégie les
scolaires pour les petits puissent être
à l'heure aux états l'établissement
bonjour l ena donc j'ai à voir est ce
qu'il ya des correspondances à attendre
ou pas tout est à l'heure donc on peut
partir alors alors à plus tard lna c'est
très agréable de conduire un train parce
qu'on a un paysage on est un bureau plus
tôt
vachement agréable quand on a la chance
on voit du gibier des cerfs des biches
chevreuils relancer notre quotidien
quand il ya la belle saison c'est
grandiose quoi tient la neige c'est
encore mieux
la ligne ferroviaire et les on dit à
écartement métriques un mètre de large
qu'ailleurs ça m'aide 40 et ça pour les
passionnés du ferroviaire c'est quelque
chose d'historique nous sommes une
espèce de petit sncf puisque nous avons
tous les métiers conductique conduit des
trains accompagnateurs agents de gare
maintenance de la voie ferrée et tout ça
on le ferait avec à peu près 65 salariés
c'est une très belle gare il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui viennent pour prendre
le train mais aussi pour pour prendre
des photos et pour regarder le site en
lui même
[Musique]
à commencer par les eaux bonjour quand
un jeu prendre aussi en plus des oeufs
je vais prendre une petite pyramide on a
dans le berry un merveilleux pâté de
pâques qu'on aime tellement qu'on le
fait toute l'année un petit peu l'enfant
s'en veut dire c'est c'est le pâté de la
grand-mère quand on allait manger
dimanche midi chez elle c'est une
vieille tradition de à base de porc de
devaux ça peut être fait aussi avec de
l'agneau ou avec un du chevreau 3
échalotes merci beaucoup génial avec moi
je mets du cognac alors avec le cognac
le persil et les échalotes
ça donne mon goût
sa taille dont sandra alors le bout et
j'ai en effet qu'elles soient pas couper
trop enfin je pense que chaque fois tu
es gay berrichon a un goût différent
selon part qu'il est fait de toute
manière on a chacun 500 petits secrets
et ça se vend très bien ça se vend bien
toute l'année parce que ça se mange
chaud où ça se mange froid
puis ça se mange dans une assiette ça se
mange avec les doigts on pique nique sur
un buffet en apéro en tout petit avec
des oeufs de caille
bonjour ryan que va bien et quand jabara
alors aujourd'hui je vais me mesurer à
toi pour une première fois
tu vas faire un pâté et moi aussi
[Musique]
avec la patte et berrichon j'aime bien
un petit côté de fumée qui sans lâcher
un petit peu donc je rajoute du lard
fumé et j'aime bien ajouter aussi subi
la ciboulette et cerfeuil qui un peu
plus en maîtrisez vous fait un petit peu
plus léger moi non mais moi j'ai c'est
qu'il soit pas trop cuit je fais 12
minutes départ eau froide
soucieux de mettre le même partout comme
ça le coup ils sont sept clips pareil là
j'ai fait un petit tapis de farce
je vais venir poser les oeufs durs
dessus les oeufs durs pas trop cuit je
vais leur mettre leur petit à petit à
petit de farce par dessus
[Musique]
la musique tout de suite à on va et
voilà vingt-cinq minutes le tiens on le
sent bien le le cognac
c'est la première fois j'ai vu ça on
voit bien le les lobes voilà dans mon
enfance mais les yeux étaient bien
marqué chacun avait son oeuvre
[Musique]